a ceasefire appears to be holding
between Israel and the Palestinian
militants in Gaza after one of the worst
outbreaks of violence there in five
years
both sides have launched hundreds of
rockets and missiles at one another
since Friday more than 20 people have
been killed in Gaza and four more were
killed in Israel Seth Doane is in
Ashkelon Israel near the Gaza border
Seth good morning good morning there is
a sense of relief here this morning
after what residents tell us was an
absolutely terrifying 48 hours we are
inside one of the homes that was struck
by a Palestinian rocket which landed
just outside smashed these windows you
can see glass and debris on the floor
here and the man who owned the house was
killed Israel's military struck back
hitting about 350 targets in the Gaza
Strip one of those Palestinian targets
had been riding in this car Israel's
military says it was a senior Hamas
figure it was the first targeted
assassination by Israel since 2014
Palestinians say an infant was also
killed in one of the air strikes her
body was carried in a funeral procession
her father said the children were
playing and were struck by a missile
shot from a drone Palestinians fired
close to 700 rockets and projectiles
toward Israel about 200 of them were
intercepted but one hit near this house
well we see the substantial damage
Lieutenant Colonel Jonathan Cahn Rica's
showed us the damage today he says this
round of violence was sparked after
Israeli soldiers were shot at by
Palestinians during weekly Friday
protests at the border
these cease fires seem short-lived do
you have any confidence that this will
hold of trying to militarily destroy
Israel it leaves very little room for
optimism Palestinians condemned what
they called Israeli aggression amid an
unfolding humanitarian crisis in Gaza
this morning Israel's Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu said that the
military campaign is not over yet Gail
thank you very much John reporting from
Israel